we've announced this morning a billion
in profits for the year ended March but
we will have effectively no passengers
for the three months of April May and
June is a remarkable number for the
business that we only lose you have
something north of about two hundred
million during that quarter when we have
no passengers and our entire fleet has
been grounded when we last spoke you
were announcing that you were resuming
flights in the beginning of July is that
still on course well sort of what's
happened since then it is and your
bookings are building nicely and I think
we could they got a major Philip over
the weekend when the Italians announced
that from the 3rd of June they're
reopening the country they're removing
the hopelessly ineffective 14-day
isolation that nobody can police are
implement anyway and I think a lot of
European countries most notably those
over that they're reliant on tourism
will over the next number of weeks lifts
their restrictions they'll waive this
40-day isolation rule which is idiotic
and non science-based and I think we'll
see people moving again with some degree
of freedom in July and August
as long as in the case of Ryanair our
passes and our people are all weary mass
because it looks like masks is the most
effective way of preventing any
recurrence of covert 19 or the spread of
covert 19 where is I mean the 14-day
isolation of the British government have
announced is completely ineffective
because you people coming in from
airports getting on the London
Underground or the Gatwick Express
trains and London on the ground and yet
apparently only when they arrive at
their destination then they have to
isolate but nobody on the trains of the
underground has to isolate it's nonsense
so do you think the UK government is
singling out aviation for particularly
harsh treatment no I think they're just
you know frankly just making stuff up as
they go along and they're stumbling
along grabbing whatever they think will
make a headline but there's no science
to base there's no scientific or medical
basis for a 14-day isolation for air
passengers when you're not applying that
equally to London Underground passengers
are London commuter train passengers and
we heard Grant Shapps over the weekend
talk about would we need to reduce the
volumes on the underground by 90 percent
or how do you do that and when you ask
that these questions they're completely
unable to answer them so I think what we
need is more
effective government more effective
measures and really the most effective
measure at the moment as we reopen our
economies is everybody wearing masks
whether that's in shops in underground
stations on bosses or an aircraft you
better the 14-day quarantine period
Spain of obviously still got that in
place you're optimistic Spain will drop
that into your course we think it'll be
dropped particularly in the tourism
destinations on the beaches where you
know what if you look at Spain most of
their covert problem has been in the
major high population density cities
Madrid Barcelona and some of the others
same in Portugal it's been in Porto and
Lisbon it's not in the Algarve it's not
been on the beaches and I think those
countries will over the next couple of
weeks as we believe the British
government will - will focus on how do
we reopen the tourism economy during
kind of July August that the tourism
economy creates a huge or sustains a
huge volume of employment and we've got
to get these sectors back moving again
in a way that maximizes public health
and that is facemasks not idiotic 14-day
isolation in somewhere where the
government can't to find where you would
actually even isolate and the bookings
that you've been taking since you
announced that you were resuming flights
from the site in July
what sort of prices have they been
compared with last year ah well down on
last year I mean we're selling seats at
the moment to Spain to Portugal to Spain
or to Italy in Greece at you know 39 29
39 one way I mean we've lost the
availability in July and August and what
we're seeing though is family groups
making bookings I mean it's quite clear
to us that you know the British public
British public the Irish public are
going on holidays to Spain to Portugal -
easily those countries will open up
they're generally going on their
two-week annual holiday anyway so they
can manage a kind of a 14-day isolation
period but we think those isolation
periods which are hopelessly ineffective
and in fact unmanageable will be dropped
in the next couple of weeks we hope in
favor of more effective measures such as
temperature controls and face masks and
what progress are you making on refunds
we're doing well given the historic
battle we have in Weaver
about 50 million refunds to process
those far over the last six weeks food
now processed about 300 million euros
worth of refunds were about a quarter of
the way through the backlog and we'll
continuing to process refunds but as we
reopen we see more and more customers
taking voters are more imporantly free
moves of their original booking into a
future booking in July August or
September so the message for customers
who are concerned that they haven't
received a refund here is is what be
patient bear wages be patient we will
get there but remember I mean our our
refunds team has been reduced by
three-quarters because of the social
distancing regulations in our offices
here in in Dublin in Spain and in Poland
we are processing refunds if you want a
cash refund you will get it just be
patient but take us some weeks or months
to get it to you